the show fantasy celebrated its 23rd
anniversary this past October and they
have some very special surprises for the
holidays and joining us to tell us more
our cast members Mariah Rivera Lorraine
apparel and Ashton Bray welcome ladies
thank you you guys look so festive you
look so beautiful thank you 23 years
congratulations Mariah how has has it
been I'm sure you haven't been there all
23 years
but I have been there 14 years now and
I've started as a swing dancer and I've
worked my way up to now co-produce her
so I'm very honored and blessed and it's
just such a great show at Luxor that
we're just keep winning Awards and keep
changing the show every year so we try
to always keep it fresh how have you
seen it evolve over your 14 years then
we had uh originally when I came in the
cast we had Chris Judd who was married
to JLo at the time choreographed a bunch
of stuff so now we've uh kind of
transitioned we have a couple guest
choreographers come in but then we also
have some of our dancers have
choreographed some of the numbers in our
show so it's a good opportunity for
everyone to show their skills it's a lot
of skills involved Lorena your skin
skills your specialty I mean you can
sing and dance but really that voice is
amazing thank you so much
favorite part of doing this
I love people I love hosting I know I
love singing I do I love doing bad
comedy
I I just love entertaining and then
Anita's giving me this platform on
fantasy that that's this is where I grew
that's where it all started was fantasy
so I'm forever grateful that I learned
that it's so much fun well you guys have
the best show Ashton tell us a little
bit about what you guys are doing for
the holidays yeah we love the holidays
here at Fantasy we have some extra shows
the 23rd 24th and 25th we're doing an 8
o'clock and a 10 30.
um Christmas Eve Christmas and New
Year's we're doing gift basket giveaway
how do you win one of the gift baskets
what do you guys do just gotta go to the
show come to the show we're gonna
randomly pick an audience member for
each show the eight and the 10 10 30 to
randomly get this basket if you come
make noise if you continue both we'll
find a special way to to pick that
random what kind of things are in the
basket we have a lot of fantasy
merchandise we have our shot glasses we
have our fantasy calendar we also have
some festive Christmas stuff some
Christmas cookies and uh yeah yeah I get
so excited when they win they're like a
Price is Right do they realize that none
of you come with the baskets
I love the way you guys um you cater not
just to like maybe that male audience
but the females women feel so empowered
when they go and see you can you guys
give um an example of like some some of
your moves that maybe people watching at
home can kind of do to feel you know
more confident sure well anytime I'm
someone's like I'm not a dancer but I
want to feel great I always say plant
your feet okay right because you can't
fall down okay and then it's about
feeling your hips and your body anyone
can do that anyone can do that and feel
good and then you can move your arms
[Laughter]
[Music]
well we would love to hear Lorena your
beautiful voice would you mind giving us
a little sample of what we're gonna add
it up here all right we're gonna step
off and hand it over to you
Rocking around the Christmas tree at the
Christmas party hop
a mistletoe hung where you can see every
couple try to stop
Rocking around the Christmas tree come
to Fantasy you win a prize
and everyone dancing merrily in a new
old-fashioned way let me hear you out
there and you will get a Sentimental
Feeling when you hear voices singing
let's be Charlie
there you go rocking around Merry
Christmas and thank you for having us oh
thank you guys thank you so much for
coming you've got to check out fantasy
uh